Okay.
This is the last class of the section on black holes and relativity,
I should say.
This particular section has of the course has gone into direction.
I didn't quite expect.
We've done a little more,
uh,
gone a little more deeply into the theory.
Uh,
we haven't done quite as much on a actual observed objects.
that's not such a terrible thing.
I'm quite happy with that.
I just want to point out a couple of things that were on the syllabus that we
didn't get to because they're very interesting things.
You can look them up on the little black hole website and find out all sorts of
things about them.
Uh,
and one of them is,
uh,
there exist,
a category of a what's called supermassive black holes.
Uh,
I mentioned the black holes that are,
uh,
that come from stars and I'll talk about that much more today,
but I don't think I'm going to have a chance to talk about the supermassive
black holes.
These are black holes that live in the centers of galaxies and can have masses,
uh,
of hundreds of thousands,
millions,
sometimes even billions of times the mass of the sun.
So very massive,
uh,
black holes,
in
these centers of galaxies,
including our own galaxy,
by the way.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it is gas falling into these black holes.
The powers,
the quasars,
we saw a gravitational,
the lensed are the other day.
These are very,
uh,
very powerful sergeant sources of emission,
that are located in the centers of galaxies,
sometimes called active Galactic Nuclei and,
uh,
they're caused by these very massive black holes.
So that's one thing we're probably not going to get to.
Another thing is,
uh,
I had it originally intended to talk a little bit about gravitational waves.
Uh,
we,
uh,
I mentioned that in the context of the fact that,
the mission of these waves causes,
uh,
causes the orbital periods of things like the binary Poles are,
and indeed all orbits in principle to gradually become shorter.
The orbital period,
the semi major axes gradually become shorter.
But there's also the hope it hasn't yet been done,
that you could detect these waves directly,
that you can make a kind of telescope that would actually observe gravitational
waves.
This is now in progress.
It hasn't yet succeeded.
Uh,
so these can in principle be directly detected,
uh,
that hasn't been done
yet,
but
it will be soon.
I think there's something called the laser interferometer for,
um,
her gravity observatory.
[inaudible] Lyco,
uh,
which is basically a,
a kilometer long hunk of metal,
uh,
the length of which can be measured to some fraction of the size of an atom.
And when a gravitational wave rolls over this,
uh,
what you expect to happen is you should see the thing getting slightly longer
and slightly shorter as the wave goes over it.
The problem with this is that the effect of passing trucks on highways 10 miles
away is many,
many times greater than the effect of passing gravitational waves.
Uh,
and so what they've done is they built two of these things once and one in
Washington state and one in Louisiana.
And the plan is to operate them simultaneously so that you can see,
uh,
things that happen in both places might be attributable to some cosmic source.
There's a whole bunch of other stuff,
uh,
to talk about this.
It's a fabulous experiment.
Uh,
and,
uh,
as I say,
we probably won't get a chance to talk about it in detail,
but you can go to the black hole website and that has links to all sorts of
other things.
And you may,
uh,
if they succeed in this,
somebody is winning the Nobel prize.
Uh,
and so you may find out about it by reading in the paper five years from now or
so.
Yes.
Hmm.
Have we ever directly observed a supermassive black hole?
It depends what you mean by directly observe a,
by definition,
you can't directly observe a black hole.
Uh,
we infer their presence in almost exactly the same way that we infer the
presence of the small black holes,
which I'm going to talk about now,
uh,
namely by watching things orbit around them.
And so basically what you,
for example,
in the center of our own galaxy,
uh,
there's,
a one mil,
uh,
I think 1 million,
3 million,
I don't remember some number of millions of solar masses of stuff right at the
center of the galaxy.
You can tell that because of the orbits of the,
of the stars closest in,
uh,
which emits no radiation at all.
And so there's something down there that's extremely massive and totally dark.
And we know that that's true by watching the orbits of nearby stars.
And we can actually carry out this same kind of observation,
uh,
in the centers of other galaxies.
And as far as we can tell,
there's one of these supermassive black holes in the middle of every significant
galaxy.
Uh,
and that's actually been one of the achievements of this kind of astronomy over
the past dozen years or so,
is to demonstrate in each case for which we have enough data.
There seems to be,
uh,
an extremely massive invisible,
something down in the middle of these states.
And there are other reasons to think that they're actually black holes rather
than,
you know,
a 100 million neutron stars or something silly like that.
Uh,
and uh,
and so we're pretty convinced by now that
these things live in the centers of galaxies and were quite convinced that
there's one in the middle of our own galaxy.
Yes.
Why are they in the middle of all the galaxies?
This is actually a little bit of a mystery.
How these things get made is not clear.
It's pretty clear how the,
uh,
stellar mass,
the 10 solar mass ones get made.
It's the collapse of a single star.
Uh,
how,
uh,
how these things build up,
how they grow,
where they came from in the first place is a little less clear than it is for
the stellar mass things.
Uh,
there is recent work which suggests that the very first generation of stars was
quite massive.
Thousands of solar masses rather than an in,
uh,
stars of one solar mass or something like that.
And it maybe this first generation of stars collapsed down at the thousand mass
black holes and then a whole bunch of them ran into each other and fell into the
centers of galaxies.
But I would have to say that that isn't entirely clear where these super massive
things come from in contrast to the situation with uh,
uh,
10 solar mass black holes where we have,
where we have,
if not a detailed theory,
at least a good handle on,
uh,
the broad,
story of where they come from.
Yeah.
Okay.
So that's what we're not going to talk about.
So now let me talk about what we are going to talk about it.
Uh,
sort of a Meta lecture I guess.
let's see.
Um,
what we,
last time I talked about the binary pulse are,
and that was an example of,
uh,
a very detailed test of post Newtonian relativity.
And what I want to talk about now is strong field relativity,
relativistic effects,
uh,
that,
um,
uh,
that have nothing to do with Newtonian theory that are totally different and
then happen when you're a really very close to an event horizon or in some other
kind of drastic situation.
So here's the plan.
Uh,
here's how you would,
how would you go about testing the predictions of strong field relativity?
Well,
the first thing you'd want to do is find a black hole.
Yeah.
Not just talk about them,
but you know,
be able to point in the sky to where one of them is
and then you'd like to study it and find out,
uh,
whether this thing you think is a black hole,
actually behaves as general relativity would predict for such an object.
And you in particular,
there's this very strong prediction from relativity and it's such a thing would
not have a surface that,
uh,
it would have a
okay,
an event horizon
down which things would disappear.
Uh,
not
a surface of any kind.
And so what I want to talk about today is,
uh,
both of these steps.
Um,
and the story starts,
uh,
in the late 1960s,
in the middle of the 1960s,
uh,
when,
the first x-ray astronomical observations of x rays were made.
So it starts with x ray astronomy.
Um,
one of the features of astronomy for the past half century or so is that,
uh,
you know,
in,
in the 1950s,
by the 1950s,
there had been a lot of astronomy,
but it all,
all been done in optical light with optical telescopes.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the story of astronomy for the past 50 years has basically been one after
another of different kinds of electromagnetic radiation,
not optic,
other than optical light have gradually been opened up.
The first of these was radio astronomy.
And so all of a sudden,
people point radio telescopes at the sky and they find out all sorts of things.
One of which,
for example,
was pulsars,
which we talked about the last time.
Uh,
the next,
uh,
part of the electromagnetic spectrum that was opened up was x-rays.
Now x rays,
there's a problem with doing x ray observations,
which is that x rays don't make it through the atmosphere.
The atmosphere is completely opaque.
Tax rates,
this is a good thing.
Uh,
the sun emits x-rays.
and you would not want to be in a place in which you didn't have an atmosphere
to absorb the x rays on the way to yourself.
You'd get skin cancer immediately.
Uh,
and so the fact that the,
um,
uh,
the atmosphere absorb x rays is good for everybody except for the x ray
astronomers because it makes it difficult to do these kinds of observations.
So this only got started at the point where,
uh,
you could put satellites into orbit outside the atmosphere and equip them with x
ray detectors.
Basically,
Geiger counters.
Uh,
I,
you know,
there's a lot of talk these days about going back to the moon.
Uh,
and,
uh,
one of the very few scientific exam,
advantages of a moon colony is that you could do ground based ex-ray astronomy.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
you picture a hobbyist in his backyard,
where that kind of Geiger counter in a coffee can or something going outside and
observing x rays from the sky.
Uh,
and I think that would be a great thing.
but,
uh,
I digress.
Uh,
let's see.
X Ray Astronomy.
Yes.
In the 1960s.
So they send up Geiger counters on satellites and,
and increasingly sophisticated a x ray telescopes over the years.
And they discovered something that they didn't expect.
Namely,
so this is now in the 1960s.
Also around the same time the pulsars were discovered.
Uh,
they also discover a very strong sources of x rays,
x rays,
sources,
and these,
there's a lot of energy coming out of,
out of these things.
Thousands of times,
uh,
even hundreds of thousands of times.
Uh,
the radiation that the sun emits.
Yeah.
Radiation and,
and from these ex-ray sources,
essentially all of it in x rays.
Okay.
There's a small amount of optical radio,
other kinds of radiation.
But basically these are ex-ray emitting stars.
There's stars that he met,
huge amounts of extra and luminosity and not a whole lot else.
Uh,
and they're very,
very,
very powerful.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so people wondered what these words,
these were unexpected.
Nobody had predicted that this would,
uh,
be there.
And as they started to think about what these things might be,
they realize,
well,
what is an x Ray?
And X ray is a very energetic photon,
very short wavelength light.
Therefore,
each one of the photons carries a big punch.
So these are energetic photons,
uh,
and the more energetic the radiation that is emitted in,
in,
in sort of general terms,
the hotter at the material,
but he admits it has to be just in order to,
to,
to crank up the energy a you need.
That's why a ordinary objects at room temperature glow in the infrared.
Uh,
if you heat them up,
they start at two thousands of degrees,
things start to glow in the red.
If you heat them up still further,
you get white light,
blue light.
Uh,
if you crank things up to hundreds of thousands of degrees,
you start to get ultraviolet radiation.
And it turns out,
uh,
in order to get x rays,
you need to have things,
uh,
that,
have been heated up to millions of degrees.
So,
uh,
energetic photons would come from a US require high temperature,
by which I mean,
you know,
a million degrees or so.
Uh,
by contrast,
the sun and other stars and other similar stars,
uh,
has a surface temperature,
of about 6,000 degrees.
That's hot enough to glow in the optical,
uh,
but not hot enough to generate large numbers of x rays.
And you can also go further and say,
uh,
you can figure out how much radiation ought to come from a given volume of
million degree,
whatever it is,
uh,
and you discover,
so combining,
uh,
the temperature and the,
luminosity,
uh,
there's a little formula which I wrote won't write down,
which tells you how big the thing has to be in order to emit that much
radiation.
If the sun were five times bigger,
where'd he meet?
Five squared?
More,
uh,
more radiation.
And it turns out that if you combine this stuff,
uh,
the emitting region is small.
Yeah,
much smaller than an ordinary star.
There's another argument,
completely different argument that,
that,
uh,
whatever is emitting these ex,
these x rays has to be small,
which is the following.
Uh,
the brightness of these things varies.
So also,
here's the second argument.
Brightness varies and it varies quickly,
uh,
hundreds of times this second hundreds,
so on timescales of,
you know,
one,
100th of a second,
the brightness of these things can vary by a factor of two or more.
Now that immediately tells you that the size of the region that is emitting the
radiation has to be smaller than one 100th of a light.
Second.
Because imagine here's the thing,
the team meeting radiation and a,
so it's got,
you know,
photons coming off in all directions and you're kind of over here watching the
thing.
Uh,
if it's suddenly changes brightness,
uh,
you'll see the brightness change from the front part of the object before you
see the brightness change from this part of the object.
Because this part of the object has less of a distance to travel to get to you.
And so the amount of time it takes light to get from one side of this object to
the other is a kind of a minimum amount of time that you would expect to be able
to see a change in the brightness.
Now you can ask,
what if just this little piece gets brighter?
Well then that little piece,
uh,
had better be emitting essentially all of the radiation.
You see,
uh,
when it,
all of the increased brightness of the radiation that you see.
And so then you just apply this same argument to that little piece.
And so the size of this has to be less than 0.01 of a light second.
Now light is three times 10 to the eight meters per second.
So,
uh,
the size of these things has to be less than three times 10 to the six meters.
Uh,
that's less than what,
3000 kilometers.
This is something that's,
so all this radiation thousands of times,
uh,
the radiation,
that you see from the sun,
all of it in x rays has to becoming from something that's substantially smaller
than the earth.
And in fact,
some of these things a very on timescales,
even smaller than that.
So lots of energy,
very small object,
this point you again towards neutron stars,
uh,
because they can pack a punch in a relatively small volume.
And as,
uh,
these objects were studied more and more,
um,
a picture came,
a came up of what they actually were.
And these are things that are called ex-ray binary stars,
binary meaning a double star,
two stars in orbit around one another.
And the idea here is that one of these stars is a kind of ordinary star.
Like the sun got a slightly weird shape,
which I'll explain in a minute.
Uh,
so this is some kind of relatively ordinary star.
Okay.
And the other star in the system that it's orbiting around is,
uh,
well the generic term is compact object.
MMM.
An example of which would be a neutron star
or potentially a black hole.
Uh,
and the deal is that these guys are orbiting so close to each other that if you
look at the gravitational force on a,
an atom of gas at this point of the star,
oh,
I should say the reason that star is this weird shape is because of huge,
is his basic.
This is basically a tide.
This,
uh,
pulls one part of the star towards it,
and that distorts the ordinarily spherical shape.
And so this is,
you get this kind of teardrop thing,
and if you analyze the gravitational forces on an atom of gas here,
it's pulled in two directions.
It's pulled downward by its build towards a,
at the ordinary star,
by the gravity of the ordinary star,
but it's also pulled in the other direction by the gravitational force of this
other thing and whatever it is.
And at this sort of a teardrop,
a place here,
this,
this peak here,
uh,
the gravity
okay,
uh,
toward the Compact object is greater.
And that means that the surface of this particular point on the surface of the
ordinary star,
in fact,
that material is pulled off the star and pulled onto the compact objects.
It kind of,
what happens is it kind of goes into orbit and it ends up orbiting around the
Compact object.
So you have a gas stream
and all this stuff ends up in a big disc of material here called an accretion
disk.
And so basically the gas goes into orbit around to the Compact object.
Now you know something about orbits.
So these are perfectly ordinary.
Each atom has its own little orbit.
Uh,
the orbits are perfectly ordinary orbits,
which can be described by the usual set of equations.
And one thing you know about that is that the inner,
uh,
or bit go faster than the outer orbits.
And so if you imagine two pieces of gas sort of right next to each other,
one inside the other,
inside,
one has to go faster.
And so they rub against each other the different parts of the gas.
So,
uh,
this gas generates friction
and friction does two things.
First,
uh,
it heats the stuff up.
Okay.
And the,
and where does the energy for that?
He'd come from?
It extract energy from the orbit.
Okay.
And that in turn leads to the gas spiraling in.
So the gas in this disk gradually spirals in as it does.
It emits a lot of,
it creates a lot of heat,
generates a lot of radiation.
And what was demonstrated in the early 1970s is that the inner parts of such an
accretion disk can be heated up to millions of degrees,
which is exactly what you want to be able to explain the x rays.
So inner accretion disk,
okay.
Uh,
goes up to millions of degrees
and that's where all these x rays are coming from.
Okay.
So that's what these,
uh,
x ray sources are supposed,
in principle to be a,
and there's now by now a lot of,
uh,
a lot of evidence that this general picture is basically true questions.
Yes.
The accretion discs,
yes,
absolutely.
These are also observed around supermassive black holes.
That's where the light from quasars comes from,
from accretion discs around the supermassive black holes.
They have it too.
Again,
the question of where that gas comes from is a little less clear than it is in
the case of the x Ray binders.
But yes,
this is why,
uh,
so there's two ways you know that the supermassive black holes exist.
One is from the orbits of stuff around them and the other is from the emission
from the accretion disk,
but there isn't always gas.
The one in the center of our galaxy,
there is no accretion disk.
And so we don't see it at all.
And so in some cases they're creating gas in other cases,
not presumably that's also true of black holes and binary star systems that
there are some of them that aren't close enough to their companion to pull mass
off and you know,
uh,
and we don't see them as bright x rays sources
army are not getting,
sorry.
Does that mean,
does that necessarily mean that the nearby objects are not getting pulled apart
by the black hole?
The nearby objects are not getting pulled apart?
Well,
the uh,
uh,
the companion star is gradually being stripped of all its gas by the black hole
in this case.
But if it were a little further away,
it would be a perfectly stable orbit.
Yeah.
Other questions?
Yes.
Oh,
this is smaller.
That's bigger.
Yes.
If you're a contract out there,
just a neutron star,
could it also be a full,
sorry.
Uh,
in principle it could,
in practice it turns out that all that gas swirling around does bad things to
the magnetic field and to the radio emission.
So in practice they tend not to be pulsars,
but in principle they could be
pull,
start by definition,
like one desk oriented in such a way that we can see it.
The CW,
well,
I mean it depends on exactly how you define it,
but a pulse are,
is something that ha that emit radio from an off axis magnetic field.
Presumably if it doesn't happen to cross us,
we wouldn't know it's a pulse are,
but somebody else in the galaxy mine.
Other questions at this point?
All right.
So having found a bunch of these x Ray Binary's,
the question is,
can you tell whether they're black holes or not?
And now let me remind you that the mass of a neutron star has to be less than
three times the mass of the sun.
So the plan is you observe the orbit of the companion,
uh,
and determine,
okay,
the mass of the compact objects.
Okay.
And there's a,
uh,
there's a derivation you can do,
which I won't show you,
but again,
you can look up on the,
uh,
on the black hole website,
which shows,
uh,
remember what,
what we're doing here.
Let's observe the radial velocity of the companion versus time goes up,
goes down,
and you determine two things from this,
the orbital period and the amplitude of this sine curve,
which I'm going to call k.
And it turns out you can prove,
uh,
the following a relationship.
This is actually easy to prove,
but it takes,
it takes three pages to do it.
So I won't,
uh,
I won't go through the exercise that PK cubed over two Pi g,
is equal to the mass of the Compact object.
The mass of the thing.
You don't see times sign cubed.
I,
I'll explain that in a second times plus the mass of the object that you either
they choose the ordinary star divided by the mass of the Compact object.
And this is squared.
So now why would you do this?
This is,
so this is a little calculation.
You start with Kepler's laws.
You do three pages of Algebra,
you come out with this,
uh,
it's written down on the class of server.
Why would you do that?
Why would you express it in this particular form?
Here's the deal.
This is called the mass function.
Uh,
so called,
uh,
and uh,
it is,
can be observed from the velocity curve only.
Yes.
The whole term.
Uh,
only that's called the mass function.
and the term on the right here,
it's very interesting because it's the mass of the object.
You don't see
massive,
the Compact object times something that is less than one sign of any angle.
Oh,
I should take the I here.
This is the inclination of the object to the line of sight.
Uh,
if it's it coming exactly toward towards you and away from Ui is 90 degrees.
If it's going around this way,
it's zero.
That has to be in there because you're observing radial velocity.
But it doesn't matter what this is a sign of anything is one or less signed
cube,
Dev,
anything is one or less.
So this term up here has to be less than one.
Uh,
this term of the bottom,
uh,
has to be greater than one.
It's one plus something squared.
So,
uh,
on the bottom you have a term that's greater than one.
That means that this quantity,
which you can easily observe is less than the mass of the Compact object.
Yeah.
So if the mass function,
if you measure the mass function and it comes out to be greater than three solar
masses,
then the compact object,
there's also greater than three solar masses.
And if that's true,
uh,
it has to be a black hole because it has to be small,
smaller,
so small that it could otherwise only reasonably be a neutron star.
And yet it's bigger than the mass of the neutron star itself.
There's a Ma moderate technical problem with making this observation.
And the problem is
this is hard to observe
because the,
um,
the accretion disk is too bright
out shot.
So the creeks in discount shines the star.
Uh,
fortunately nature solves that
problem for us because many of these objects
have,
yeah,
intermittent.
Okay,
accretion.
So the accretion happens.
You see all these x rays,
then the accretion turns off for various reasons.
Uh,
and then when the accretions off,
all you see is the companion star.
And so you can win the accretions off.
You can make this measurement.
So here's how you go about finding a black hole
first.
Uh,
suddenly there's a new source of x rays.
The X rays turn on in one of these transients system.
Then you wait.
Okay.
Then the x rays turnoff.
This happens after a few months.
Typically
once the x rays turn off,
that means the accretion disk isn't there anymore and you measure the mass
function.
Okay.
And then if that's greater than three solar masses,
you win,
namely you've discovered a black hole.
Uh,
and uh,
this is a sequence of events that I'm rather fond of.
This is what got me tenure.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
I thought I'd just show you an example of how this works out in real life.
Let's see.
Okay,
here is,
uh,
well let me turn the lights down just slightly.
Okay.
Right?
So this is just a sort of artist's conception of an x,
right?
Binary.
Here's the companion star.
Uh,
here's the accretion disk.
Down in the middle there is a compact objects.
So small you can't see it.
This red stuff is supposed to be radio emission coming out of the polls.
Uh,
and you can see the little gas stream going from one to another.
This is what it looks like when it,
when it's x ray active.
When it,
when the x rays turn off,
what happens is the,
uh,
stuff just piles up in the outer part of the accretion disk.
There's not enough friction to drive it down in there.
No X rays.
And basically all you can see is the companion star.
Okay?
So let me now take you back 15 years in time.
This is something that crossed my desk shortly after I came to Yale as an
assistant professor in the early 1990s.
Uh,
this is an astronomical telegram.
A,
that's an old fashioned word.
Now,
of course,
we do it all by email.
Uh,
and these are a system for distributing the results of Fast Breaking News in the
heavens.
Do you know if you see a supernova or some exciting or comment or something
exciting going off in the sky,
you can't wait to publish it for a year and a half because by then it will be
gone and no one else will,
will study it.
So we have this system for distributing news of fast breaking events so that
other people can study them.
Uh,
in this particular case,
there's a whole bunch of astro jargon down in here.
The titles,
the only thing you have to pay attention to x ray transient in the constellation
of Musca new extra source suddenly appeared in Musca.
These,
these guys found it.
Uh,
you've probably never heard of the constellation of Musca Muscow the fly.
Yeah.
Uh,
there's two reasons you haven't heard of it.
One is it's in the southern hemisphere.
You can't see it from here.
Uh,
but the other reason is it's a pretty pathetic excuse for a constellation.
It's one lousy fourth magnitude star.
That's why they call it the fly,
right?
Uh,
but they had to call that part of the sky something.
And it's now my favorite constellation because it has this object in it.
Anyway,
a bright x ray stores suddenly turned up in Muskoka,
uh,
a month or so later,
the x ray source was still bright.
I found myself in this lovely spot.
This isn't observatory in the,
in Chile,
uh,
where you can see the southern hemisphere among other things.
And the two telescopes pictured here.
This is was at the time,
the largest,
most powerful telescope in the southern hemisphere.
This is the door,
just to give you a sense of scale and this thing here in the foreground,
which looms large in this picture,
but it's actually much smaller than that,
I have to tell you,
is one of the more far flung outposts of the Yale Empire.
Uh,
this is Yale's one meter telescope.
It was built in Bethany,
Connecticut.
And then in the late,
in the early 1970,
somebody said,
well,
Connecticut's are really stupid place to have a research telescope.
It snows all the time.
And so they kind of picked it up and took it down to Chile.
Uh,
and uh,
so it's,
it's a buy now only our second best research telescope and I'm very fond of it.
Uh,
and so I found myself observing at this telescope a few months after the
discovery of this x ray source in Musca.
So I junked the program I thought I was going to do and looked at that thing
instead.
And what I found was that every 10 and a half hours it got a little brighter.
And then a little fainter and then a little brighter.
And I,
this was the,
uh,
the,
the accretion disk was still there.
So presumably this was some effect,
for example,
of the companion start crossing in front of the accretion disk or something like
that.
Uh,
and so I fired off my own telegram.
There's two things you need to know from this one.
That's me.
Uh,
and the other one is that,
uh,
I claimed that there was a 10 and a half hour modulation in the brightness of
the source,
which might be the orbital period.
That's an interesting thing to know because if you know the orbital period,
if you know,
pee in the mass function and you think that this might turn out to be a black
hole,
you can figure out how big K has to be in order for this to be a black hole.
And the answer is that if you were to measure the radio velocity of this thing,
the difference between the maximum and the minimum radio velocity would be 800.
If that were 800 kilometers a second or greater,
then the compact object in this system would have to be a black hole.
Problem was,
I couldn't make that measurement because first of all,
the Yale telescope wasn't powerful enough to do it.
Second of all,
uh,
the accretion disk was still too bright to allow observations of the companion.
So I teamed up with a couple people who had done this once already before.
Uh,
Ron [inaudible] from Mit,
Jeff Mcclintock from the Smithsonian,
and we applied to get time on the big telescope.
The big telescope,
which I showed you is from the National Observatory and you have to write a
proposal to get time on it.
Many people want to get time on it.
It's quite competitive.
But we wrote a good proposal.
And so the following year after the x rays and turned off,
they gave us three nights of telescope time on the big telescope in order to
make this radio velocity curve.
So,
uh,
just to orient you,
here's chilay.
Uh,
here's the Capitol Santiago,
Sarah to is up in the Andes here.
Uh,
so you take this enormous plane ride and then drive up to,
uh,
drive up into here.
Uh,
and then what happened was,
let's see,
the first night it rained,
this is kind of an occupational hazard.
You,
the reason there are all these telescopes in Chile is because it's mountains in
the desert,
which is an excellent place to put telescopes.
As it turns out,
even in the desert,
sometimes it's cloudy,
sometimes it range.
That was the first night.
So that was out,
uh,
the second night.
Oh,
that was interesting.
There was a hailstorm.
I,
I don't know if you've ever been in a six story,
high hollow steel building in the Hale.
It's a very interesting experience,
but it's not productive scientifically.
And so,
you know,
they give you these little rooms to sleep in which our light tight and,
uh,
and sound tight because you have to sleep in the daytime.
And so there's this very dramatic moment.
You wake up at four in the afternoon and you raise the shame to see if there are
clouds.
So fortunately,
the third of our three nights,
it was all clear the storm had passed.
Uh,
and we were able then Nassau,
now we're sitting somewhere in this building.
Uh,
and we were able to make our observations.
So let me show you what we did.
Here is a plot of hours,
time in hours on the night of the 3rd of April,
1992 versus radio velocity.
So this is going to be a radio velocity plot.
First thing we observed was this point right after sunset.
And you notice that the object is coming toward us at 250 kilometers a second.
That's already very good news because 250 kilometers a second is actually a
little greater than the escape velocity of the galaxy.
And so the only reason something would,
uh,
have that kind of speed is if it was an orbit around some other nearby object or
objects in the galaxy.
Don't,
aren't usually that bright.
So we made a couple more observations.
Uh,
and after the third observation,
it was clear that at the basic parameters of this system,
uh,
were,
more or less correct.
And it started off coming at us at 250 kilometers a second,
couple hours later.
It was going away from us at 200 kilometers a second.
So in a mere two hours,
it had turned itself around from coming at us at a high rate of speed to going
away from us.
So that's good.
It's in an orbit and attended an orbit with a very short period.
Uh,
and so that was a very encouraging.
and then,
uh,
we collected more data and by about midnight we were feeling pretty pleased with
ourselves because you can see what's happening.
It was coming.
It's now coming,
uh,
going away from us at 400 kilometers a second.
But clearly it's about to turn around and go this way.
If you extrapolate five and a quarter hours before this turnaround,
you'd get a point down here.
That meant it would have been going from minus 400 to positive 400.
That's 800 kilometers a second.
If you believe that,
then this probably is a black hole.
So we're feeling pretty pleased with ourselves.
Uh,
we opened a little bottle of the local firewater awful stuff called Pisco.
you're not supposed to do that,
right?
You're not supposed to operate heavy machinery.
Uh,
uh,
and,
nature was not kind.
We were punished for this.
Uh,
there was a small earthquake,
uh,
a Chili's in an earthquake zone.
And so the,
uh,
this does bad things for precision aligned optics.
So the next point was a little skew for reasons that we never explained in our
paper.
And then there was a gap,
uh,
where for a little while we didn't take any data while we were straightening
ourselves out again.
And then here's the next point.
And so now that's,
that's encouraging again.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
more data was collected toward the end of the night.
And so as dawn was beginning to come up,
uh,
we were kind of backward.
We started,
the thing was coming towards this a 250 kilometers a second,
and we really needed one more point down here in order to nail the whole thing
down.
Uh,
the problem was that the object of course,
is now setting in the west.
Uh,
you know,
the earth turns.
So objects rise in the east,
they set in the West.
If you can picture a telescope following an object down into the west,
it's port of pointing like this.
Uh,
the principal optical element in this telescope is a huge mirror of four meter
wide mirror.
So 13 feet across and it's not bolted down particularly cause you could put
bolts in the mirror,
changes in temperature,
will change the size of the bolts and it'll throw the optics out of alignment.
So it's just kind of sitting there and it's tipping this way and eventually it's
going to,
you know,
fall out,
fall on the floor.
It is way more than seven years.
Bad luck for an astronomer to break the primary mirror of the largest telescope
in the southern hemisphere.
And so they don't let the astronomers actually move the telescope themselves.
That would be far too dangerous.
They have trained experts to do this and the trained expert was saying to us at
this point,
you know,
you've got to stop observing this object.
We're beyond the safety limits and so forth.
We said as scientists,
do you no,
no,
no.
In the interest of science,
we must have one more point.
Uh,
this argument went on for a while,
uh,
and they were about to,
kind of,
uh,
pull the plug on us and then we said,
okay,
fine.
You know,
we understand safety of the telescope is paramount,
but the argument,
uh,
we'd accumulated one more point.
And so this is kind of the clinching case down here as it's coming towards us at
400 kilometers a second.
So we're very pleased with ourselves over breakfast.
We did the exercise of finding the best fit sine curve.
Here it is.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
if you work out what the mass function is,
the orbital periods,
10 and a half hours,
the mass function is 3.1 times the mass of the sun.
So very good,
very good news.
Uh,
you'll notice this plus or minus 0.05,
the data is not all that great.
We've subsequently gotten a lot more data on this thing.
It does turn out to be about 3.1,
but it's also true that remember that that formula had this sign I in it and we
were able by other means to determine what the inclination is.
And it's now clear that this object hasn't caught,
that this binary system has a compact object of a mass of about seven solar
masses in it.
Very,
uh,
a very nice thing.
Uh,
we published this paper,
uh,
other people have published other papers by now.
Oh,
here's our telegram from the next morning.
Uh,
again,
Gobbledygook,
uh,
except for the fact that the value of the mass function is 3.1 providing
dynamical evidence that the primary is a black hole.
So we want it to publish a paper,
you know,
entitled Black Hole found in the constellation of Musca.
People were a little cautious about that.
They said,
you know,
you haven't yet proved that Einstein's relativity is correct if Einstein's
wrong,
this doesn't necessarily have to be a black hole.
And we said,
come on,
you get to assume that Einstein's right.
They said,
Eh,
maybe not.
So we get to call these things dynamically confirmed black hole candidates.
That's the official word.
Uh,
and here is the current collection of these things.
Scale to the sun and Mercury.
The one we were looking at,
very close one.
This is a,
that's 10 and a half hour orbit,
this thing,
much bigger,
30 hour or bit much bigger companion star.
But all of the,
uh,
black holes in here are sort of between five and,
between five and 15 times the mass of the sun.
And so now 15 years later,
there's a whole collection of these things.
There's also a collection of things that turned out to be new trucks,
stars.
So now you can do an experiment and you can do an experiment in general
relativity and whoops,
here's the derivation.
I'll skip that for you.
And you can ask yourself whether you've bent horizons actually exist.
So here's the experiment.
You have a dozen or so things that are neutron stars.
You'll have another dozen or so things that are black holes.
You pour gas onto both of them.
Uh,
and indeed,
you know,
that's what the companion stars are doing.
That's why they have all these x rays.
What happens if of gas falls on a neutron star?
It picks up a lot of speed.
It starts going at the speed of light and it hits right into the surface.
And so when it hits the surface,
all its kinetic energy,
all its thermal energy has to stop the kinetic energy stops and all that energy
goes into the surface of the neutron star,
somehow at what's called a boundary layer and has to in some way get reradiated.
It basically heats up the surface of the neutron star.
You get x rays from this surface layer gas falling onto a black hole,
doesn't do it.
It falls right through the event horizon and the kinetic energy and the thermal
energy in that gas just contributes to the mass of the black hole and it doesn't
get reradiated.
So your prediction is for the same amount of mass falling onto a neutron stars
onto a black hole,
you would predict that the neutron star would be brighter because all of this
extra energy brought in by the accreting material would be radiated.
Whereas in the case of the black hole,
it would not be,
it would just be captured by the black hole itself.
So,
uh,
with a,
with the most sophisticated recent x ray telescope,
people have tried to measure,
uh,
black holes and neutron stars incomparable in,
in a situation where they emit comparable amounts where,
where the mass accretion rate,
the amount of mass that's being accreted is comparable.
So the black things here are the black holes.
The open circles are the neutron stars.
This is a measure of brightness and it's logarithmic.
So this is 10 to the minus eight,
10 to the minus six in some silly set of units.
Uh,
and so this between here and here,
that's a factor of a hundred.
This is the orbital period.
The reason they plot the orbital period is there's good reason to think that,
uh,
the amount of mass accretion is proportional to the orbital period.
So you expect long orbits to have more master creation than,
than shorter ones.
But the point of this graph is clear.
There's a,
there's a gap you can drive a truck through of about a factor of a hundred in
the brightness between the neutron stars,
the things that we think our neutron stars and the things we think of as black
holes.
And so the interpretation of this has been that the,
that the black holes don't have a surface because if they had a surface,
then all of this extra energy would have to radiate as it does in the case.
So the neutron star,
so this is a first step towards a,
a test of strong field general relativity.
It's only a first step because you really have to understand how much mass is
falling and what the geometry of the mass flow is.
And a whole bunch of very complicated gas dynamics.
This is sometimes called gastro physics.
Uh,
and so that's what we're working on doing now to try and understand exactly
what's going on with these things.
Uh,
and if one understood that,
then you might take such a plot to represent,
uh,
a proof that event horizons exist.
And so that kind of brings you up to 2007 in the study of strong field
relativity and black holes.
And that's the end of this section of the course.
That's the end of this section of this semester.
Uh,
have a good break and we'll,
uh,
you know,
torment you with a test afterwards.